What is the best placement for my ball?
Is it better to place it directly on my right breast?
This person has breast cancer
that was removed and radiated three years ago.
I have been just making sure it was under the cover,
but want to know if I should put the ball directly on my mind.
So I have always said that it's better,
the closer it is to you, the better it is.
But if you're using the amplifier,
you don't have to get it close to you at all.
You could have put the ball underneath your bed
if you're using the amplifier.
So if you're not using the amplifier,
I think the closer it is to you, the better.
Is it best to be right over the cancer?
Yes and no, it's not necessary.
It's first it has brain cancer.
We have some people with brain cancer
who's put the ball right by their head.
I would find it difficult to sleep myself doing that.
So that's not what we typically recommend.
The frequencies are strong enough,
even if you don't have the amplifier for it to traverse your body
just by putting it near your body
and it doesn't have to be next to your brain
if you had brain cancer.
However, closest to the body part of the cancer is always best.
Except if you have the hands on firing,
you could put it farther away.
But if you had no evidence of disease,
past breast cancer, you need to put it right up against the breast
that was removed.
No, I'd say putting it next to your body is just fine.
Let's see if you could think wisely here.
It's like, okay, if I had breast cancer,
had my breast removed,
I'd have been radiating it three years ago.
Currently, no evidence of disease.
Using the right to keep me that way at this point,
where would you most likely get recurrence of the disease?
Yes, you could get it at the site at the chest wall,
but likely you'd get recurrence of the disease
in my lung, in my liver, in the bone with breast cancer.
So if you wanted to go through your bone body,
so I think you're fine if you just put it down
at your tummy and you're struggling with the bone.